Ethiopian Airlines says all 157 people
have been killed in the crash of a
Boeing 737 max jet the airliner lost
contact with air traffic control minutes
after taking off from addis ababa to
nairobi kenyan Ethiopian Canadian
Chinese passengers are said to be among
the dead the plane was the newest
version of the 737 it was just four
months old
the tracking website flightradar24 says
a plane had an unstable vertical speed
well let's bring in our correspondent
Melanie Cora debauchees in Nairobi where
the flight was headed she's been
following the latest developments for us
hi Melanie we just heard they're from
Kenya's transport secretary on the
nationalities onboard we understand that
people have been gathering at Nairobi
Airport the flights destination tell us
more about that yes people are outside
Kenyatta Airport at this moment they
have been gathering there this is where
the flight was supposed to arrive at
around 10:30 a.m. but it never did and
of course you know the country is in
mourning Kenyans as you've just heard
our highest number of casualties people
here have been reaching out on social
media that have been messages pouring in
one of the people was the President
himself Uhuru Kenyatta he was one of the
first people sending out a tweet this
morning in which he said we are saddened
by the news of an Ethiopian Airlines
passenger aircraft that is reported to
have crashed six minutes after the
takeoff enroute to Kenya my prayers go
out to all the families and associates
of those on board as you can see people
are at the airport right now they're
there to support the families and the
friends and whether it's online or
whether it's at the airport everyone is
of course asking the same question how
could this have happened and what is it
that caused the crash in the first place
Melanie let us know what authorities are
saying at the sport obviously
investigations are ongoing but what do
we know about what happened
there is still a lot that we just do not
know we know that the plane took off
early this morning that just took six
minutes for it to come down we know that
there have been certain rescue
operations going on all of the morning
and of course no one survived in the end
people here just do not know what to
think the authorities are trying to give
them as many details as they can but
they just don't have any all the
information that we can rely on is from
its European airlines themselves and of
course you've had the minister just now
speaking out that he is trying to send
people that they are trying to do
everything that they can in order to
find out more and to support the
Ethiopian authorities but at the end of
the day we will just have to wait
all right hours a correspondent Melanie
queried about for us in Nairobi thank
you very much as Melanie said Kenya's
Transport Secretary's held a fresh press
conference on the crash he confirmed
that dozens of country's citizens were
on board the plane here's what he said
though at least 35 nationalities and
regrettably Kenya is the highest without
two passengers on board we are yet to
confirm the fit of those passages and
that's why we are sending senior
officials to Ethiopia to be able to
conduct the sourcing of information in a
bit of fashion DW semion SF has been
looking into the plane involved in this
crash he joins us for more I mean so
this plane we know it was manufactured
by Boeing first of what is Boeing saying
right now well Boeing issued a statement
today giving their condolences to the
families they said Boeing is deeply
saddened to learn of the passing of the
passengers and crew on Ethiopian
Airlines flight 302 a 737 max 8 airplane
they extended their sympathies and they
also offered help with any technical
issues that will happen after a specific
investigation into what caused this
this crash which there's no information
about that at this point yeah we see
that statement as you said there from
Boeing what about this specific plane we
said it's a 737 max what do we know
about it
well this plan is almost brand-new it
came out in 2017 it's supposed to be
more fuel-efficient but it has been
involved in two deadly crashes since it
was released the earlier one being just
at the end of October the India the lion
air crash in just off the coast of
Indonesia that killed 189 passengers an
initial investigation into the cause of
that crash showed that it could have
been linked to a malfunction of an anti
stall system that was not announced to
the pilots so what could have happened
was that the plane was the information
from the computer system showed that the
plane was going into an ascent when it
wasn't and forced the nose to come down
there's no information about whether or
not this happened this error happened in
any other planes 737 max but people are
obviously asking those questions yeah
very troubling indeed what did Boeing
say after that first crash the lion air
crash
well they issued a software update but
there was a controversy because of pilot
trainings now pilot trainings are very
expensive and often when a new plane has
a new software and it they won't train
new pilots because as Boeing said and
this has been their official line pilots
should be able to deal with any kind of
should be able to override a plane
system if something is going wrong this
is in standard training for a long time
now but questions are now rising whether
or not this error is something that is
causing too much of a risk that pilots
should not have to deal with so there
that controversy is still lingering
remember this was only five months ago
that the plane went down so
investigations are still ongoing into
the plane crash in Indonesia
yeah we of course have to see what
exactly happened in this incident but
how many of these planes are out there
how common is the Boeing max right now
it only accounts for about 2% of
Boeing's fleet but that's because it's a
new plane if you look at how many
undelivered new planes there are
and Boeing's stock it accounts for about
80% of those undelivered planes so
basically what Boeing is saying is that
this is the plane that they're banking
on this is going to be the future of
Boeing again no information about
whether or not this error is related to
this more recent crash today but if this
does become an issue it could really set
back Boeing alright DNS of looking to
this aspect of the story for us thank
you so much